[ROCKET ROARING]
FLORINA MUNTENESCU: Earlier
this year, we launched
a preview of Android KTX--
a set of extensions to
the Android framework
aimed at making your
development with Kotlin more
clear, pleasant, and idiomatic.
Since then, we had
several releases,
including contributions
from the community.
We changed the name to core-ktx.
And now, we're launching
the 1.0 alpha version
as part of Jetpack--
our set of libraries aimed
at accelerating Android
development.
The core-ktx library
contains extensions
to the features and
functionality of the framework.
But we didn't forget about
other Android Jetpack
libraries-- old or new.
Classes from Android X,
like fragment manager,
collections, live data reactive
streams, and the new navigation
component have
associated KTX artifacts
leveraging the features
of the language,
such as extension
functions and properties,
lambdas, named and
default parameters.
Now, let's check
out some examples.
Without KTX, performing
a fragment transaction
requires starting a transaction,
triggering an action
like adding or
replacing a fragment,
and then deciding on one
of the four commit methods
based on whether the commit
should be scheduled or call
synchronously, allowing
state loss or not.
fragment-ktx adds the
transaction extension function
to the FragmentManager
class, removing
all the begin transaction
and commit boilerplate,
as well as providing default
values for sync and state loss
that you can easily overwrite.
To avoid forgetting to call
show when displaying a toast,
and to simplify the code,
use the context extension
function from core-ktx.
Working with the Spans API?
We added extensions
to the main classes--
span string, spannable string,
and spannable string builder--
to make the API easier to
use and more idiomatic.
So for example, creating
a spannable from a string,
making the text bold,
and only a word red
can be easily done like this.
Make your menu items
eachable-- perform actions
on each item in the menu, check
whether a specific item is
or not there, or
remove items easily.
Using the Android X supported
SQLite database, when
implementing database
transactions,
you need quite a
lot of boilerplate.
With the sqlite-ktx, you
can focus on what matters--
the operations that you want
to make in the database.
And then, just let
the transaction method
handle the rest.
The new navigation component
from Android Jetpack
already offers a domain-specific
language for working with it.
So for example,
to set up in code
a navigation graph
with a search action
that saves it from hitting the
Back button 10 times to get
through all the past
results and has animations
for entering and exiting,
you would write something
like this.
You would create the graph
based on the start destination,
add an action for search
with a destination ID
and navigation options.
In the navigation options, we're
setting the search fragment
to be launched as SingleTop with
an enter and an exit animation.
So core fragment
navigation and others--
all of these are the first steps
towards a cleaner, simpler,
and more idiomatic Android
development with Kotlin.
And we won't be stopping here.
Follow us on GitHub, YouTube,
and Twitter for more news.
[ROCKET ROARING]